- He was a martial artist,
actor, teacher, and philosopher.
He is widely considered to be
one of the most influential
martial artists of all time.
He is often credited with
helping change the way Asians
were presented in American films.
He is Bruce Lee and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(intense music)
- You see, actually, I do
not teach, you know, karate
because I do not believe
in styles anymore.
I do not believe that
there is such thing as
Chinese way of fighting or
the Japanese way of fighting
or whatever way of fighting
because unless human being
have three arms and four legs,
we will have a different form of fighting,
but basically we have only
two hands and two feet.
So styles tend to not only separate man
because they have their
own doctrines and then
the doctrine became the
gospel truth, you know,
that you cannot change.
But if you do not have style,
if you just say, well, here
I am, as a human being,
how can I express myself
totally and completely?
Now that way you won't
create a style because style
is a crystallization, you know?
That way it's a process
of continuing growth.
When I look around, I
always learn something.
That is, to be always yourself
and to express yourself.
To have faith to yourself.
Do not go out and look for
a successful personality
and duplicate it.
Now that seems to me that
that is the prevalent thing
happening in Hong Kong.
Like they always copy
mannerism, but they never start
from the very root of his being
and that is how can I be me?
A good martial artist does
not become tense, but ready.
Not thinking, yet not dreaming.
Ready for whatever may come.
When the opponent expand, I contract.
When he contracts, I expand.
When there is an
opportunity, I do not hit.
It hits all by itself.
Often times people come up and say,
"Hey Bruce, are you really that good?"
I said, well, if I tell you I'm good
probably you will say I'm boasting.
But if I tell you I'm no
good, you'll know I'm lying.
I said empty your mind.
Be formless, be shapeless.
Like water.
Now you put water into a cup
it becomes the cup.
You put water into a bottle
it becomes the bottle.
You put it in a teapot
it becomes the teapot.
Now water can flow or it can crash.
Be water my friend.
In case you have missed the recent news,
Jeet Kune Do, of which I am the (mumbles)
has been elected and accepted into the
Black Belt Hall of Fame in America.
This marks the first
time a recently developed
form of martial art is nationally accepted
though Jeet Kune Do is not thousands
or even hundreds of years old.
It started in around 1965
by a dedicated and intensified
man called Bruce Lee
and my martial art is
something that no serious
martial artist can ignore.
I have no fear of opponent in front of me
but I am very self-sufficient.
They do not bother me
and that should I fight
should I do anything
I have made up my mind
and that's it, baby.
You better kill me before.
What was that, an exhibition?
We need emotional content.
Try again.
That's it.
How did it feel to you?
- Let me think.
- Don't think, feel.
It is like a finger
pointing a way to the moon.
Don't concentrate on the
finger or you will miss
all that heavenly glory.
- Well, you know, everyone
talks to me about Bruce Lee
because Bruce Lee and I
were very good friends
and we trained together
for like three years
before he left for Hong Kong
to pursue his movie career.
I didn't hear anything from
Bruce for like two years.
Then out of the blue, Bruce calls me.
He says, "I've done
two movies in Hong Kong
and they're really successful.
I want to do a movie
now with a fight scene
that everyone will remember
and I want to do the fight
scene in the coliseum in Rome
and I want you to be my opponent."
At that time I held the world title
and kiddingly I say to Bruce,
"Well who wins, Bruce?"
And he said, "I win, I'm
the star of this movie!"
And I said, "Oh, I see.
You want to beat the world champion."
He says, "No, I don't, I want
to kill the world champion."
(screams)
- Thank you guys for watching.
I made this video because
the B-Thong asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Bruce Lee's tips
you find most relevant, most
helpful, most practical.
Leave a comment below
and I'm curious to see
how the discussion goes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.